merci aux bouffes martinique express et
bonsoir bonsoir à vous tous vous pouvez
le constater ce soir notre ami guy lux
n'est pas là il est parti il prendre
quelques jours de repos bien mérité il
était également notre ami guy lux
retirer un oscar mais oui l'oscar de la
presse et de la télévision marocaine au
titre de meilleur présentateur de la
télévision française anne oscar bien
méritée et ainsi j'espère que lorsqu'ils
nous regarderait le profitable aux
applaudissements mais tout de suite pour
ce ring parade je vous laisse en
compagnie du hit-parade men d'europe 1
notre ami christian morales
leurs troupeaux vous avez été
merveilleux mais c'est certain bonsoir à
tous et bonsoir à tout heureux de vous
retrouver tour sur ipad